hallöchen meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer weiteren
folge der micro factoring unter anderem
diese schlafschaf ich mein chef und
diese scheinen hier das auch dabei unter
anderem auf das gras hier und irgendwie
sind hier echt schon krass viele tiere
ich freue mich dass wieder eingeschaltet
hat hier heute zu viel bei seiner
fernsehsendung alter freue mich dass ihr
wieder mit dabei sein bei die minecraft
felix ich habe mir 56 rausgesucht und
wir fangen an mit denen mit dem mit dem
ersten projekt und wenn effekt habe dann
schreibt man die kommentare und dann
würde ich sagen viel spaß beim video
freuen müssen wir bis zum ende dran
bleiben würde und danach erst die
bewertung abgibt und nicht vorher weil
das bringt mir sonst ich finde übrigens
weiß ich warum ich so fertig aussehe
das liegt alles an der webcam bewahren
natürlich nicht gestern am feiern an
meinem geburtstag
diese web kein mensch einfach die kamera
spendieren oder richtig dumm ich will
die immer so unter hauen aber die ist
einfach so
die ist so fest an meinem bildschirm da
verankert es geht einfach nicht egal mit
welchem aspekt nummer eins ist eine mega
simple sache die mir selber aufgefallen
ist in der command folge und zwar habe
ich ja den kudamm shader drin meine
lieben freunde alle die nicht mehr
fahren wartet das mit shader kula shaker
burschen fünf ultra so und wenn ich
diesen bruder shader drinnen habe und
jetzt beispielsweise mal hoch fliegen
über die höhe von den wolken könnt ihr
sehen durch die wolken durch kann ich
alles total anders sehen die partikel
werden komisch angezeigt es wird alles
einfach so ein bisschen anders angezeigt
und wenn ich jetzt einfach mal
beispielsweise über die wolken
drüberfliegen seht ihr wenn ich nicht
durch die wolken schauer ist das ganze
so wieder dieses vernebelte und so
weiter das bin ich halt so geil an dem
shader dass das alles so ein bisschen
vernebelt dargestellt wird auf
entfernung aber wenn ich durch die
wolken durch schauer sind einerseits
wasser und lava partikel extrem komisch
so komisch war ich hab nichts gegen
schwarz aber das ist schon ein bisschen
komisch und halt allgemein wie das sonst
ein bisschen anders aus und guck mal ich
habe schatten in der wolke alter sie zu
halten die sonst einen riesigen schatten
auf dem boden aber ich denke ihr wisst
was ich meine hier sieht man einmal den
unterschied beziehe den kontrast ganz
gut zwischendurch eine wolke
durchschauen ganz normal gucken also das
ist ein ganz simpler fag nummer eins und
das sieht schon recht interessant aus
unbedingten sachen aber das ist auf
jeden fall erstmal effekt nummer eins
und wir kommen direkt zu fact nummer
zwei wo freunde ich befinde mich hier in
etwas hoher höhe und wenn ich hier ich
habe keine rüstung an das kann ich euch
zu zeigen wenn ich hier unter falle wäre
ich ja eigentlich normalerweise schon so
gut wie tot also ich hab ich glaube ich
kann den effekt euch gar nicht zeigen
weil ich dazu gar keine herzen aber ich
muss mich mein ganzes leben selber köln
wollte den effekt nämlich ich teste
jeden fall irgendwie wenn ich bevor ich
eine folge aufnehme
deswegen habe ich den wohl vorhin schon
getestet und deswegen hatte ich gar
keine herzen jedenfalls befinde ich mich
gerade in einer höhe wenn ich runter
fallen würde wäre ich eigentlich
normalerweise tut oder nicht nun
allerdings in den game mode 0 g und
hierunter fallen und ich hab kein bock
zu sterben und ihr habt eine ender perle
mit dabei wenn ihr irgendwo runterfällt
und ihr denkt ich sterbe einfach eine
ende perle irgendwo hinwerfen und guckt
euch druck jetzt enter und während die n
appelle dahin und ich bekomme nur diese
zweieinhalb herzen schaden die ich
normalerweise durch das teleportieren
einer perle bekomme diese standards
schäden einfach und zwar einfach sonst
nicht darunter gefallen wäre und mich
einfach hätte runterfallen lassen wäre
ich einfach komplett gestorben aber wenn
ihr da oben seid und fallt ist es
komplett egal also das ist nicht so wie
mit einem minuten tier was ich euch mal
gezeigt hat bastian alleine habt und ihr
könnt das ein bisschen immer hoch und
runter ziehen wenn ihr das dann ganz
langsam unterlass stirbt es trotzdem
weil diese stätten diese fall schäden
übereinander dieser höhe wird dann quasi
addiert hier ist das nicht der fall also
es ist egal ich kann auf zehn jahre
schon runter fallen und kurz vom boden
diana perle schmeißen
das läuft die beta perle muss nur auf
dem boden aufkommen bevor ihr auf dem
boden aufkommt weil sonst seid ihr halt
einfach tot und das ist auch wieder ein
ganzer block nummer zwei ist aber ganz
interessant und wird denke ich einigen
leuten schon weiterhelfen ja so freunde
für den dritten weg nehme ich mir hier
beispielsweise einen tintenfisch und ein
schwein und ich denke sogar dass
schweine zwölfte nicht mehr rum
aber wir haben es ja schon gewusst wenn
ich beispielsweise nicht zeigt sich mal
zuerst mit dem schwein hier
ich kann natürlich wenn ich sonst bauern
ein von einem schwein einfach unseren
links rein läge in so einen amboss kann
ich das umbenennen und wenn ich das
beispielsweise dinner bauen nenne kennt
ja meine damen und herren habe ich
glaube ich damals ging man schon mal
vorgestellt vor einigen folgen das ist
schon sehr lange her dass wenn man tiere
irgendwie gramm oder dinner bonn oder
job nennt dann haben diese bestimmte
andere sachen die die
ja ich zeige es euch einfach mal als
wenn ich ein tier winterwochenende dann
dreht sich das halt um das kennt ihr
natürlich schon allerdings bei einem
tintenfisch funktioniert das ganze nicht
also ihr habt ihr gesehen und das ding
heißt auch dinner bauen und mich das
jetzt einfach mal hierhin platziere seht
ihr bei einem tintenfisch hinter das
nicht das ist genau gleich
das ist komplett egal das liegt nicht am
wasser oder so wenn ich ihr schweine
mainz wasser setzte drehen sich auch um
also jedes naht ich ich ich meine sogar
jedes entity ding also nicht endet die
ding sondern einfach jeder mob dreht
sich um wenn ich das in bonn nenne außer
ein tintenfisch jetzt nicht bei so
sachen probiert wie nimmt zombie fährt
oder irgendwie sowas weil da hatte ich
keinen bock dass osborne und es gibt das
wird ein spannender muss ich ein command
nehmen und blabla da bis jetzt halt
nicht probiert aber bei den normalen
mobs diesem spiel auftreten ist es meine
ich nur bei dem tintenfisch so dass der
sich nicht um dreht wenn man den so auf
den abonnent sondern diesen halt ganz
normal und diese schweine die er da
schon seit umgedreht das ist ein verbot
mir auch schon wieder vergessen ganzen
namen vorzulesen wurde mir vor gesendet
von eric dann kann dich eric und wir
machen direkt weiter dass wir voll
steine folge alter viele meilen also
redet immer am heißen brei herum doch
besser was los freunde ich kann auch auf
den punkt kommt in wirklichkeit habe ich
einfach nur mega hunger und wer gleich
einfach zum piano gehen um mir so zehn
packungen nudeln holen oder irgendwie
sowas er deswegen würde ich das ganze
jetzt einfach hier schnell aufnehmen
eben weil ich einfach weniger hunger
habe übrigens dank an alle glückwünsche
da ich hab mich mega gefreut dass so
viele an einen geburtstag gedacht haben
alter so freunde ihr kennt es natürlich
ich habe da ein tnt beispielsweise und
hier und wenn ich dieses tnt hier jetzt
einfach mal anzünde und mir das ganze
jetzt aus der entfernung anschauen seht
ihr schon dass eine tnt explodiert okay
das ist jetzt das paradebeispiel dafür
dass er explosion schaden genau bis zum
anderen tnt geht zeigt euch mal hier
einfach so dass ich hier die nahezu
direkt nebeneinander mache einfach nur
noch mal um zu bestätigen dass kennt
natürlich auch jeder minecraft spieler
ich habe einen tnt das explodiert und
dieses tnt durch die explosion schaden
aktiviert ein weiteres tnt außer der
explosion schaden geht genau bis zum
zehnten und macht das halt nicht
aktivieren tun sein was habe ich hier
jedenfalls funktioniert das ganze nicht
unter wasser und zwar hat mir das dmc
kit zugesendet und zwar wenn ich jetzt
beispielsweise meinte anzünde obwohl das
ist hierzu halb über wasser damit mir
gar nicht so sicher aber ich meine
jedoch es funktioniert auch nicht und
zwar wenn ein anderes thema unter wasser
ist und das andere hier auch unter
wasser und blau und das eindeutig dann
anzünde damit dass andere davon nicht
hier
quasi nicht aktiviert das haben wir ja
hier vorn herausgefunden dass das da der
fall war wenn das über land ist wenn das
allerdings unter wasser ist wieso über
land was lara ich weiß auch der piste
wenn das aber unter wasser ist dann ist
dies nicht der fall also ihr könnt ruhig
ganz ganz viele tnt unterwasser
nebeneinander setzen die werden nicht
irgendwie voneinander aktiviert ganz
einfach weil unter wasser halt kein
sachschaden getan wird von dem tnt also
tnt wird nur aktiviert wenn da irgendwie
schaden gemacht wird oder so bzw
die blöcke in der umgebung halt zerstört
werden und ich habe hier glaube ich sehr
viele tiere umgebracht sehe ich gerade
so freunde für den 5
werden wir uns mal eben in den neckar
bewegen als viel auf über noch so diese
ganzen auf kopf getreten tiere rum und
zwar seht ihr schon wenn ich hier bin
hier ist ein schneemann unter fragt sich
natürlich erstmal wie kann dieser
schneemann überleben
sie schubste mal eben hier kurzen die
lava und da seht es mich schon dieser
schneemann hat nämlich feier resistance
alles ich grad mega cool aus mit dem
puck doch jetzt hier mal vernünftig
hindu oder du ja solch ein schönes
feature und zwar können schnee naja
eigentlich nicht in der hülle überleben
also wenn ich jetzt hier schneemanns
bonner seite schon der ist einfach tot
aber wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise
einfach mal einen schneemann sporne und
den mieten abwehr mit einem verbalen
trank der feuer resistenz abwerfe dann
kann er in der hölle überleben also ist
er damit quasi feuer resistent das ist
an sich eine mega simple sache aber habe
ich mir eigentlich noch gar nicht
überlegt weil ich dachte man kommt mit
der hitze nicht klar aber wenn sie
natürlich feuer resistenzen ist ja
weihnachtlichen vier stammen könnte hier
überleben und ich meine es geht sogar
wenn ich die ganze zeit eine
gesunde heißt es dass gesundheit heilung
sei ja eine halb ocean ein werk waren
dank der heilung ich meine nämlich damit
geht das ganze auch wenn ich die
dauerhaft damit abwerfe so ich werde
denn jetzt dauerhaft mit den bergbahnen
trank der heilung ab das steht ihr auch
also der schneemann bekommt wirklich
schaden hierdurch aber wenn ich den
jetzt die ganze damit abwerfe dann kommt
der kein schaden wenn ich jetzt aufhöre
seht ihr schon dass der gleich einfach
hier verrecken wird das ist einfach
perfekt nummer fünf schneemänner können
in der hülle überleben wenn sie denn
eine feuer resistenz haben
beziehungsweise wenn ihr in der wüste
wohnt und ihr wollt unbedingt
schneemänner bei euch in der siedlung da
haben dann werft ihr einfach mit feuer
resistenz ab ob sich das lohnt bei sie
nicht aber das ist auf jeden fall effekt
nummer 5 der mit zugesendet von wurde
von ai weiwei und ich habe sich ein ende
das war es auch schon wieder für diese
folge der minecraft facts ich würde mich
freuen wenn ihr das video mit einer
positiven bewertung bewertet und dann
sehen wir uns hoffentlich in einer
weiteren folge wieder wenn ich euch
wieder facts vorstelle
wenn ihr irgendwelche facts ist bitte
gerne in die kommentare schreiben
nochmal danke an alle glückwünsche wir
haben echt zu viele leute gratuliert
dankeschön dankeschön dankeschön so
nachfrage ich bin sechs jahre alt
geworden und wie haben topfschlagen
gespielt und dann würde ich sagen sehen
wir uns in einem nächsten video wieder
tiefs halter new day trader unter läufer
ich ein bisschen komisch oder